hi my name is Nick Kroll and I feel
strongly about Conan O'Brien's friend
[Laughter]
my friend but about Conan O'Brien's
friend yes I don't have a lot of friends
so I don't know which one you feel
strongly about I'm gonna go with I'm
gonna go with Marty Short okay I feel
strongly about Marty Short and guess
what if we contacted him right now he
would say I really don't consider Conan
a friend I really don't Marty what he's
always so good at something that sounds
like a compliment and he goes like one
of the more recent ones is Conan I mean
you've done so incredibly well when you
consider the talent you have
here's the super cut I did stumble on a
Supercut of him just roasting you on
your show on YouTube and but just
quickly if if I can just promote YouTube
if you want to go see Clips online
YouTube is a great website and this is
something you started a while ago right
yes yes yeah well it's a family business
yeah yeah well the old family name was
youtubian yeah thank you for making me
Armenian and not Jewish well yeah I mean
watch you point
thank you okay that's very nice yeah I
thought if he was our meeting you'd say
his name was Nick nikkien because that's
what you think Armenian names no no I
just I don't I can't remember your I
love your husband tack but instead of
learning his last name I always call him
taxisian and oh that's funny though but
I mean it's just it's very fun it's good
word play yeah it's very clever
I think if you as a friend we've known
each other for a while we have and uh
you are unfailingly funny always funny
thank you you really are that's a weird
unfailingly funny is it's a it's one to
navigate it's a word you don't know
exactly where you stand inside it's a
put down yeah okay
no it is not a foot no no you when I'm
around you uh we've had meals together
uh we have uh enjoyed each other's
company uh you'd all those years in on
you would come on late nights we were
just talking before the show about one
of my favorite things ever that you did
on the show which is a night every uh a
specific kind of 1970s acting that
involved a guy eating with no manners
throwing food into his mouth that also
available on YouTube yeah again great
website
I think you're my I think my first late
night appearance was on your show
um and which was a great uh was truly
like a couldn't believe that I was on
your show could not believe it right
um and so fired your agent the next day
I fired my agent I fired my publicist
and I left the business for five years I
re I reconnected with myself
uh but then I looked in the mirror every
day and I said you are unfailingly funny
yeah I was confused every day when I
when I heard the state it's a good
tongue twister too it is it's proof it's
but but truly it was and and but we did
but but then so it was it's crazy to be
on your show but then to feel like I
genuinely we've had dinner you said
we've had dinners we've had very
intimate dinners together yes we have
just the two of us yeah alone in
Manhattan Beach on the water this is a
seafood meal uh but no we have had
dinners together which is also all those
little things are are very uh been very
important for me I want to say that
there's a there's been a couple of times
where we've intentionally tried to get a
bunch of funny people together and
you're always part of the equation other
people come in and out and I take that
to mean that you're just available yes I
am I am I am always Tech Avail for hangs
I am I'll drop anything family
I am you're just you're right there I am
unfailingly available